tuvo grandes hazañas grandes campeonatos
cuando el nápoles era considerado nada
pero digamos más para atrás fue primero
después de boca va para el barcelona y
es ahí donde también tiene su rica
historia pero como bien conoce la
historia
y su parte fundamental fue en el napoli
donde
tiene grandes desbarata
quien te puede decir de él
yo soy categoría 80 y no lo viví tanto
porque en ese entonces era muy pequeño
yo pero por
decirte después por acervo si se puede
ver grandes campeonatos y además no
solamente campeonatos así sacarlo
campeón al equipo sino también
instalarse dentro de la ciudad hasta el
punto de que en el mundial 90 cuando se
produce la eliminación de italia se
juega creo si no me falla la memoria en
el estadio del napoli en el san paolo y
éste
piedad como una noticia anecdótica
porque parte de los napolitanos quería
que éste argentina logre la victoria
pero a su vez estaban ellos como
italianos organizando su mundial creo
que ese mundial le jugó en contra diego
al que en el sentido de que no le
perdonaron los italianos el haber
derrotado a su selección este hablamos
de 1990
creo que fue fue uno de los hitos más
importantes